yeah we're in a bloodshot shirt because
they were giving him out at the
screening and they were like hey you
should wear it in a video and I was like
well I can't do that I can't do it if
the movie is good anyway I can only do
it if it's bad because if the movie is
good I'm like hey bloodshot it was good
trust me and wearing the bloodshot shirt
they were giving out at the screening I
mean credibility at that point I can't
fall for that rule of reciprocation so I
was like I'll wear in the video if the
movie sucks
[Music]
so bloodshot is a Vin Diesel movie based
up the comic book character which I just
did a little light searching with my
friend Google never read the comic books
but I saw the character I was like I
recognize the character but I just
haven't read any comic books he's been
it not that this movie really provoked
me to want to but I'm sure they're fun
but this movie starts Vin Diesel if you
have seen the trailer you've already
seen too much of the movies I'll try to
break it down in a way that's less than
the trailer actually dead in diesel as a
soldier he's been killed in action and
now this corporations brought him back
to life he has nanobots for blood and
you know he's gonna want to go in his
own quest but there will be strings
attached because they literally own his
body now they can push a button like put
him right to sleep you know so there's
gonna be a struggle and this movie yes
it does feel like an early 2000s cheesy
action movie I'm sure Vin Diesel being
cast in the movie doesn't help it not
feel like that funny enough Vin Diesel
was in Fast & Furious movies then cheesy
sci-fi action movies and then fast and
furious took off again and then he was
in Fast & Furious movies and then cheesy
sci-fi action movies again circle of
life and it is cheese now the first act
of this movie I was like this is as
cheesy as it gets but I could enjoy that
we're talking to the van Damme street
fighters number one fan here I can enjoy
that then the second act tries to amp it
up but it doesn't seem to know the
difference between more plots and more
intrigue because the fact is there's a
lot more plot but there's zero injury
and then it's like dammit they're on to
us alright let's just be a generic ass
sci-fi action movie not cheesy generic
which is a bummer because the premise is
a really good premise it's essentially
Robocop but also worse than the remake
of robocop so if you didn't like that
and the script just does no favours
whatsoever because this plot lends
itself to you all right let's piece
things together and find out what's
going on any time that's a possibility
someone just jumps in there to give you
the answer it's like that side seat
driver when you're playing a video game
that maybe it's Resident Evil maybe it's
an RPG point is puzzle element you're
playing the game with a puzzle element
you got to figure it out maybe your
brother's friends in the rooms like this
is how you do it this movies like
there's actually a scene where this one
did all this guy I'll tell you about it
in a second this dudes like case you
didn't see the trailer here is just word
vomiting everything you're like oh guy
no intrigue whatsoever maybe there'll be
other moments of yet no but there's not
there was until someone just had to
explain things there are a couple of
scenes in particular where people just
have to over explain things to the
audience if you took those scenes out
you don't even have to replace them with
anything just take them out I feel like
the movie probably be better
never underestimate Hollywood's ability
to think everybody watching a movie is a
[ __ ] and that dude I'm talking about
I've got that one guy he is the worst a
total t I broke no hero and he'll chew
gum too you know like a real badass if
he's feeling it he'll take the gum put
it right under the desk like he used to
do back in elementary school you know
like the bad boys do guys what I can say
about the movie the movies just a
generic sci-fi action movie the movie
lent itself to some intrigue and
although the trailer shows too much it
still looks like other might be an
intriguing unraveling of that plot but
there's not it's just very on the nose
dialogue that explains what's happening
as the movie takes your hand and walks
you through this movie to the end the
word here is generic and those kind of
movies I'm not gonna remember in t-minus
one day yep I already forgot oh it's a
blood shot have you seen it what did you
think about it what did generic sci-fi
movie maybe it's one you like you know
that cheesy sci-fi action movie but
you're like you know what it's cool
though whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more to come to like a badass if
he's really feeling it another piece of
gum Best Buy 9 October 2017 makes sense
if I'm smacking my gum in the microphone
sorry that's terrible ASMR